uh you got a little
fun message too so it's been a fun fun
24 hours so we've been um
examining and having a you know you know
having fun having a little fun yeah
having a couple laughs poking a little
fun at a fellow youtube content creator
stuttering john melendez
starting john melendez um we've done a
couple segments of him you know talking
about how he may be an out of touch
boomer maybe on how he lives in his
glory days perhaps
on how
nobody likes him
um
nobody watches his chat anymore
how he was the worst part of howard
stern
on
that's debatable down there he's down on
that list on
how he has he worked for so long and
he's probably broke
um
how he doesn't know how to put together
an audio show even though he did radio
for 20 years and produced the jay leno
show that the old brian red band yep
uh
he he apparently didn't like that
uh
i noticed that um john melendez the
verified twitter account john melendez
he uh followed rotc revenge of the cis
he's a champ he must be i didn't follow
him back because clearly he's a fan i
don't follow him back because i wouldn't
admit to that are you crazy let me
blackballed in the community you didn't
even follow him back that's the best
part i'd rather follow jeffrey epstein
nice power move yeah [ __ ] it
you can follow us you [ __ ] loser
pretty cool power move i like it
uh
i'm going to read a
a tiny excerpt of the dm i received mike
um i'm gonna
names
may be changed
the innocent can i guess how it started
sure
first of all i just wanna say big fan
love the show guys
no
that's not oh no
i thought we were making friends royce
that's how it started i thought we were
making friends i i'm
did i misread this whole thing
i think are we beefing with stuttering i
think well i mean i don't think i'm
beefing with him i thought we were just
trying to help his show by telling him
to stop doing it i think that he may be
beefing with us um there you go by the
way this is a a photo from the hollywood
reporter so you don't own it
john
oh yeah cause cause john old johnny's
been testy
oh he's testies all right um
so i'm going to read the dm
greeting
not greetings
greetings
we're off to a great start we don't even
get two i like that greeting you
greeting and you two have to share it
okay greeting
when combat i like to just
i'm just picturing somebody walking into
a room greeting
okay
um and um just so you know this this dm
was from his lawyer because lawyers
often
professional lawyers often like to use
the direct message system on twitter for
some reason of course
and he
says i write on behalf of my client
john melendez
you have used his work without proper
from his twitter this is from john this
is from stuttering john's twitter
for this client speech so no you're the
client it's you
mike you're the client he couldn't even
copy paste and write greetings correctly
but he couldn't even get somebody to
email it from a
no or what the proper thing to do is you
send a letter a cease and desist yeah
but it released an email from not your
own twitter account
right
greeting i might as well dm
hey this is uh
marsha's totally hot girl that goes to a
different school you don't know her
hey also john trim your nose here's bud
jesus christ man you know when i was on
a howard stern show
you know i used to trim my nose hairs
but you know you know who wouldn't do it
benji benji wouldn't shave his nose
hairs
yeah
donny2247 says
when you used to have uh elegant elliott
often on
what was that like
he was okay i guess
that's this entire show
greeting it's a greeting greeting
i write on behalf of my client john
melendez
you have used his work without proper
consent in violation of federal and new
york state law
what we've broken the law royce royce if
we've broken the law i think we broke
the law we're criminals
immediately we remove
all of melendez's videos from your
youtube channel
but it's you you're melendez
failure
i love failure how is how's he doing
great
failure to immediately comply will
result in additional damages
so so we're already accruing damage
there's damages are being accrued as we
speak please
send confirmation
the videos were removed to via email to
and then there's the email and then
there's a name of the lawyer which i
won't say on here
there's an email and there's um
the name of the lawyer
so
mike
we've been warned so we we're going to
stop right
sure we're going to leave him alone hey
listen i just want to say
i'm sorry i apologize
uh i never wanted any beef with you
so we will never make fun of stuttering
joe you have my word
that we will never
make fun of stuttering john on this
program ever again however john melendez
is a different story
[Laughter]
so a couple things here johnny boy
this in our [ __ ] first rodeo so let's
start with that yeah we've been i've
been to several rodeos
and and also indian powwows wow and
sometimes i'll have them at the same
events really that's pretty cool
can we go yeah they're fun they're all
kind of fun let's do it anyway
this has happened with feld
entertainment
this is this happened with several
youtubers plenty of people yeah i don't
know if you know feld entertainment are
there the guys people that created
wringling brothers and motocross yeah so
let's start with that john
um
so what i did of course was um
this is a scare tactic by the way this
is this is to try to uh
this is to try to get a couple things
what the chinese techno fascists do a
couple things i have a couple questions
i don't understand if you're in
california
why your lawyer is mentioning new york
law
because new york law is the best law
royce okay
secondly
john melendez
read up on fair use and copyright um i
went by that i went over both of those
clips one hundred percent within fair
use not only did we pause we paused a
lot well we talked over it a lot yeah
there are times when i'm a little more
worried on our solo shows whether or not
we overstepped it
but like when we're both on a show we
don't shut up right so there's very
little of your clips that get played
because we constantly pause it so that's
how fair use works and also something
else john if you're going to go after
people without using for using clips
without their consent
you should probably stop playing clips
from the howard stern show and the e
howard stern show on your show you see
because
john
it'd be a shame
it'd be a real shame because i don't
know if you know this with this
copyright system
they allow for tattletailing
they do now i would never advocate for
this i would never tackle or weaken star
yeah
but
just letting you know now maybe when you
have 70 live people watching that
doesn't seem to be a big issue for you
john
but it will become one um
here's the other thing john
those nose hairs and i cannot see them
you [ __ ] ruined it if you think
if you
think that we can't make fun of you
without your video
boy are you wrong no we could just i'll
just reenact his show whenever we need
and if you don't think that we're going
to continue
to play your videos that fall under fair
use copyright law which has been upheld
mike in several court cases
um you're a public figure and we are
allowed
we are allowed to criticize you it's how
it works man
it's just how it works so we won't play
your clips anymore just any anytime
somebody wants to uh play a clip of your
show i'll just do this
and another thing it's like why why are
you always talking about how funny
sal sal the stock broker is i was always
way funnier than him
you want to see check this out here's a
clip from
1994 when i made jackie laugh for two
seconds
why does it say e in the bottom corner
i don't think you own that john do you
do you own that john yeah john you
shouldn't play copyrighted things john
you shouldn't do that john i think you
know better than that john um do you
also i want to welcome you john i know
you're old and you don't know this i
want to welcome you to the internet
um i think will be your guides
can i do it sure okay boomer thanks
okay boomer that's good say it again
oh okay boomer
um oh okay
all right
brendan brennan
i'm so angry
john
welcome to the internet john
um i don't know if you know this but you
are now fighting a storm
you don't
what are you [ __ ] catwoman now just
let me okay
you do all the monologues
so mad
anyway okay boomer
[Laughter]
listen
john i don't know if you know if i don't
know if you understand how this works
but
you're not gonna be endearing yourself
to the public
when you do this and you stop people
from criticizing you because john look
first off i want to let everybody know
that i've already forwarded
all of this information
to
our lawyer oh that's right john we also
have a lawyer yeah he's a real one he's
a real lawyer he's actual real lawyer um
we forward our information to the lawyer
and who's helped us on every single fair
use copyright thing that we've ever done
and we've never
ever
ever lost
um but if you don't think that i'll
john let me tell you something if you
don't think that
just out of [ __ ] principle
i'm going to
we're not going to fight back you're
insane
you get to get criticized we get
criticized on the internet [ __ ]
plenty
plenty really
oh no mike doesn't know
wait do people say negative things about
us i i try to shield you from it
i really do
um i
i
that's news to me i just i always just
assumed we were universally beloved
oh that's really disheartening uh two
master says oh please remind john that
he can't claim sirius xm audio he has on
his channel john do you have serious xm
audio on your channel i know you're
watching this john i might have played a
clip or two but just to prove how much
funny i am
than fred norris
hmm
[Music]
it's not good john it's not it's not
great john it's not good john
if if i were you
if if i were you
uh john
you can't just play howard stern audio
on your show buddy you can't
who do you think he what do you think
you're dealing with [ __ ] jim and sam
yeah who are just grateful that anybody
would post a clip to them on the
internet thank you so much thank you
so
john i have an idea
i have an idea too but it's against
tosh yeah to say it
john
john boy
what did you do john you
what'd you do
diseased livered
bloated faced
lefty boomer
we probably were just gonna leave you
alone
like most things we would have had some
fun and we didn't realize have a couple
lifts we would have gotten over and then
we would have moved on but now see but
now john
but now john
um
i don't you know what he's doing this is
hilarious
he uploaded
he uploaded a clip of him
[Music]
from the stern show
he uploaded he uploaded a clip from him
from the stern show
copied the entire video
put it on his channel
and then in the description it says
copyright stuttering john podcast
but that's
that's not how it works
he can't be this dumb right don't answer
that hey mark
heap
no way he
he got an entire video
of the e-show of the e-show an entire
video of the e-show
john this is from
howard howard stern tv which i know for
a fact
i know for a fact he doesn't own
he got an entire video and he wrote
copyright
he wrote
copyright at the bottom look you're
seeing it right here copyright
stuttering john podcast that's [ __ ]
insane
and i know
for a god damn fact
that you don't own
any of this
any of this
as a matter of fact
do you want to know
this is what uh h stern tv so this is
that's not the howard stern show howard
stern radio show howard stern howard tv
howard tv is okay uh howard tv
if this is the correct thing is owned by
siriusxm
um or e this is either e or sirius xm uh
you do not own
any of this that you're playing jon
none of it none of it so
john
maybe
just [ __ ] maybe
you shouldn't [ __ ] open this can you
[ __ ] and this isn't transformative mike
look
no it's just a clip of the show the clip
yeah no it's just a clip of the show
it's an hour it's it's an hour oh it's
an episode whole episode of the eshop
entire episode oh john
john what are you doing john
did you have the explicit rights for the
e-show john you know i had to go to
copyright you own them you know i'm a
multiple time graduate of uh copyright
school oh you got to see the happy t
friends here on youtube yeah and uh
you know i think maybe john should have
to go back to remedial copyright schemes
yeah john
john does your lawyer know
does your lawyer know that you're
uploading copyrighted material to the
stuttering john i'm gonna have to ask
you to cease and desist john shawn
this is bad john john are you aware this
looks bad
this isn't good for you john this is an
ugly situation this is very disturbing
as a matter
very disturbing um
dude just no respect for intellectual
copyright or intellectual properties
john i mean come on
three
four
five
hey mike
mike
mike
you think he owns the rights to the
jimmy fallon show
oh no and look he put his look look he
put his little [ __ ] logo look he put
his little [ __ ] logo yeah
hey
john
i don't think you own the rights and i
like that it's nutty to the jimmy fallon
show i like that it's not even his
appearance
it's a it's the guy who still works for
stern on jimmy fallon
john you're not supposed to this is bad
job other people's content on your
channel john
come on john is that really what we're
doing here this is bad news this isn't
fair use i don't see him talking over it
and saying hey
if you ask me i feel like uh stuttering
john
uh should go to prison
i think so too like at least 20 years
john did you think these stairs do you
think these scare tactics were gonna
work john is that is that is that what
you thought yeah for one we're not
[ __ ] amateurs at this two these are
not your glory days
so these are howard stern's glory days
well no not not quite either um but yet
it's it's over for you
don't do this to yourself
you can turn this around wow john
john you don't own any of these clips
john
somebody might have to go to copyright
school i wouldn't want to i wouldn't
want to have to go to copyright school i
know you were just in it it's really
really funny that's tough going it's
it's almost as bad as the dui class
so john how about this it's like an
internet dui class how about you sulk
away to your utility room in that big
five bedroom home that you live in by
yourself
and you put the micro you put you put
your [ __ ] radio shack microphone and
your 4x3 camera back on your face and
talk about how one time one time you met
tom hanks
okay why don't you do that john you know
one time we were doing the show and i
remember i was
we were talking with robin
and we were hanging out
with artie remember artie yeah that
crazy guy
anyway here's another clip of me from 20
years ago
it's so sad it's the saddest show on the
internet i think you know what it is to
have his lawyer friend from new york
write a letter
so he could copy paste it without making
sure his channel was clear of the very
same violations he's accusing us of
hey royce i don't know if you know this
but he's not a smart guy he's a
[ __ ] he's very dumb yeah he also
posted on his twitter very recently
that uh hey i'm gonna do a podcast
tomorrow
but i might not do it live because of
all the haters cause all the [ __ ]
haters dude
so
guys i'll say this to why don't we help
him out
we wanna help john out i i wanna fellow
content creator mike of course okay
so your caster here's what i'm thinking
sure tell me what you think maybe some
of our fans will like his show
maybe when he goes live or he posts a
video maybe they want to check it out
and you know encourage him i think you
guys should probably
do that i i think that would be really
fun just go there and support him and
really give him moral support let's
support let's support john melendez i
i'm
yeah let's do it
let's do it i i really honestly feel
like the guy deserves a break
so
um it's about time that john catches a
break and i think right you guys you're
right you're right if you were to go in
there and i mean overwhelm him
with your support and love
i think that would be great right well
look i'm subscribed
let me post a link here so other people
could subscribe mike i want to i want to
help him out
clearly this is the best way to do it um
there you go john there you go
there it is there's the link
um
do you know what that is that he's
[ __ ] putting a stuttering john
watermark on e and howard tv stuff oh
yeah
well i because that's the automatic uh
watermark that you put on your channel
and it hovers over your videos got it
got it but it still implies that it's
yours
in the description he says copyright or
stuttering john
well in the description he's just being
completely egregious but yeah very
egregious really john you know man come
on
so um maybe we'll help him out maybe
whenever he goes live we could check him
out yeah we check out his show i want
you guys as i said i couldn't think of a
better way to describe it than to you
need to
overwhelm overwhelm him with your love
and support please
okay guys we're going to help him out
we're going to help her put on a good
show
um and does he go live is he just doing
this like he's one of them like whenever
he gives a [ __ ] whenever the hangover
wears off
when people have no work ethic yeah i
know
like we've all had times where we're
like
do a show
because like you do it you do your job
and these guys are just like yeah like
yeah i'll roll out of bed and do it we
can move on now and by the way i want to
point out mike this entire segment on
stuttering john didn't play any of his
clips
you know one time i was oh boy i was
hanging out this is going to count it's
too accurate we were at scores oh no
with all the
and julie
and we were hanging out and i remember i
loaned him like twenty dollars and they
never saw that money again
he would remember that i want that
twenty dollars
god you know what he would be the kind
of guy that would call you up for 20
bucks that you lent him from 10 years i
loaned it to you at scores
back in 97.
hey trim your nose hairs
you [ __ ] blabbering old fool all
right we can move on he's he's doing
good i think you're just kind of we can
move on john and i'm sure you're going
to see this clip and um
just some friendly advice
i'd probably
stop uploading copyrighted content from
jimmy fallon and from siriusxm and from
e
they don't take too kindly to that